hi this is Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and author of McCain the
myth of a maverick we're on the last day
of the republican national convention
here and all the talk in minneapolis is
of the speech last night by vice
presidential nominee an alaskan pepper
pot sarah palin sarah palin gave what i
would consider and others may disagree a
rip roarin speech and i think we can
state without fear of contradiction that
she certainly excited the dwindling
number of people who attend Republican
national conventions and who belonged to
the Republican Party and therein lies
the central challenge of the Republicans
we were in Denver last week at the
Democratic National Convention on the
last day of their events and there are
people waiting in line for four hours in
the hot Blazing Sun to watch Barack
Obama give a speech here there are
thousands of empty seats in an arena at
events all over town people report that
the majority people they see her not
delegates their journalists and there's
an overall sense as there is in
Washington that there's a level of
exhaustion with the Reagan coalition and
of the Republican idea itself so yes
Palin nailed a speech but she nailed it
for an audience that's dwindling and the
central challenge for Republicans
politically this year is how to build
that audience back up for recent TV I am
Matt Welch